[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a very
very nice game uh between samuel
lerashevsky a young samuel rushevsky and
the gentleman known only as schwartz so
we do not have any info on this
gentleman or a photo of him so we are
honoring him by wearing a hoodie
now you've all seen this photo this
photo has been going um uh around
forever even before uh we we use the
internet it's a photo of young samuel
rushevsky
and he's playing against a lot of
stronger gentlemen and of course when
you see this you of course imagine wow
that that child there is a prodigy he's
going to crush those um uh gentlemen and
he will do so at a very young age so
supposedly he was eight years old when
he played this
but
we don't really know he was maybe eight
maybe he was a nine maybe he was ten uh
maybe if some of you have like uh an
eight-year-old or a ten-year-old at home
maybe you guys uh can uh you know uh
figure out whether this uh uh young
roshevsky here is uh maybe eight nine or
ten uh the fact of the matter is we
don't know i've asked my grand
grandmother once that um you know how
how did they record the uh birth uh
when she was born and that was like a
really long time ago and she said that
uh some people came to the village and
then whoever was present in the village
from the newborns they just wrote down
okay they were born on that day even
though they weren't they were born like
maybe a month ago or maybe two months
ago you know depending on when was the
last time they were there so when they
came all of the children that were new
there they just wrote down okay they
were born on this day so you know most
of them probably uh don't even have the
the actual birthday uh i'm not saying
it's like that in all the villages in
those days but uh if it was you know in
the village of my grandmother it could
also be you know some other places uh
but uh they still don't agree on uh how
old are you
exactly was here but okay he was eight
or nine or ten uh somewhere
uh
around that uh and this is not a game
from the uh from this simultaneous
exhibition so this is a game from the
simultaneous exhibition that took place
on the 16th of may 1920 even though
a lot of places say that it took place
on the 17th of may 1920 so you guys want
to remember that one to impress your
friends at the bar in the library uh
olympurkin sent me this game and also i
said that i should share this
vast knowledge with you guys
so here it is and he also sent me this
beautiful game so thank you for that
once again uh let's check out the game
and then we're going to discuss a bit
more how strong was arashevsky at this
very young age of maybe eight nine or or
ten years old so this is a game that
took place uh a month after that
simultaneous exhibition that we've just
seen it's also a game from a
simultaneous exhibition against 20
players uh so let's see
how how the game went so reshefsky with
the white pieces opens with e4
we have e6 by schwarz going for the
french defense d4 we have c6 uh
preparing to strike in the center with
the d5 and now knight to f3 uh we have
d5 striking in the center e5 and now h6
so a very uh unorthodox way of
approaching the french but it's not
unheard of it has been repeated in in
modern modern times with bishop to d3
and now bishop to b4 with check we have
c3 and now bishop to a5 there is a game
from 1997 also it was a simultaneous
exhibition in frankfurt that was held by
a vessel in topalov and his opponent
played bishop back to e7 here of course
apollo won that game very nicely but
here we have bishop to a5 and this
position has never been repeated again
uh so let's see uh how uh young
ereshevsky continues he castles his king
uh we have knights to e7 and now rook to
e1 so very standard stuff the knight
ready to come to f5 we have knights to
d7 and now knight b to d2 we have knight
to f8 uh both players are remaneuvering
their their knights knight to f1 and now
knight g to f6 um
a knight after g6 sorry uh we have
knights to g3 and now uh schwarz also
castles and now knight the h5 and this
is now an excellent square for the
knight can't really be kicked away and
it's really uh just a powerful piece
there black is uh eyeing that h6 pawn
with the bishop the knight is attacking
the g7 pawn uh the this bishop attacking
the knight here so everything is aimed
towards that black king so here king h7
uh making room uh for the rook and jade
but also uh for the knight and g8 if
needed and the king will also help
in supporting of these pawns we have
queen to d2 and not knight to g8 and now
yeah rashevsky plays g3 also worth
considering here is just g4 and g5
trying to bust open the position but
okay it's a simultaneous exhibition we
have g3 and now bishop to d7 we have
knight to h4
uh mounting the pressure as this knight
is now pinned due to the bishop on d3
bishop to e8 and now we have f4 here f4
is a fine move but a slight improvement
would have been queen to f4
of course the knight cannot capture the
queen it's been the the point is um we
are now threatening knight captures and
g6 or bishop captures and after the pawn
captures we pick up the rook so black
would have to play some like queen to e7
to guard the rook and now we play queen
to g for it now it's the same idea we're
going to play f4 f5 uh but with the king
being
a much better place on g4 but okay a
slight improvement maybe so f4 by the
shevsky king to h8 and now knight g2 uh
we have queen to e7 uh and now g4 so f5
is coming and here schwartz plays knight
to h4 and knight h4 comes with a very
serious threat uh that can very easily
be avoided that we could play some like
queen to f2 the knights get traded off
and the game continues however richevsky
as this was a simultaneous exhibition
played f5 and he allows black
a most
a devastating uh move and that of course
is knight to f3 checks so younger
chevsky completely blunders his queen
in a simultaneous exhibition against 20
players and now you might think well
okay fine that's a game over uh he
resigns now
and many people would but not young
grechevsky let's see how the game
continues with king to h1
knight captures on d2 so the queen has
been eliminated bishop captures on d2
and now e captures an f5 g captures on
f5 so white's king side is completely
ruined and now queen to d7
so what do we have here
black has a queen white doesn't and the
white only has one knight for a queen
that's not compensation at all and well
best would be just to resign but of
course younger chevsky plays on he plays
knight to h4 uh sorry knight h to f4 uh
bringing the knight back and now they're
preparing ideas like
like e6 and creating a pass pawn maybe
we have bishop back to d8 and now comes
h4 preventing bishop to g5 uh we ignite
the e7 attacking the f5 pawn and now
knight to e3 just keeping an eye on this
pawn here we have f6 trying to uh break
up the pawn chain and now ruschwski
advances the pawn to e6 and okay he
grabs even more space
but he's down a queen so what good is it
we have queen to d6 putting pressure on
the knight here knight eat the g2 the
knights are defending each other we have
bishop to c7 now pinning this knight if
the knight moves queen to h2 will be
checkmate so bishop to e3 and now g5 uh
busting open the position here and you
have to be careful now if capture is
captured then black can even move his
king bring the rook to the h file to
attack the white king
so we're gonna capture f captures on g6
alpha
uh and now uh rook the g8 going uh after
the pawn this way because uh even though
it looks like you could capture uh
because of the queen hd checkmate you
can because if knight captures on g6 we
can simply capture it with the bishop
and if bishop captures we capture with
the knight but now it's with check so
black of course cannot deliver checkmate
king h7 now we just play bishop f4 and
now we win the game if the black queen
wants to
avoid being captured queen to d8 is the
only square but now e7 and that's a game
queen eight we're gonna capture here
bring the queen into the game with check
uh queen captures knight captures with
check and after rook captures we're
gonna pick up the bishop on c7 and uh we
have of course a winning game we're up
uh a rook a bishop and a knight uh so
that's uh what happens if you go after
this so of course rook the g8 displayed
adding another attacker to the g6 pawn
but narushevsky just plays h5 and even
though white is controlling a lot more
space black is still completely winning
i mean it's a queen for a knight this is
uh unheard of
so king to g7 and now knight the h4 and
now if this knight could land on f5 then
it would be a completely different story
but how do you remove this knight from
e7 seems like an impossible task one way
is to bring the other knight somewhere
let's say the g3 so the other knight can
come to f5 as well but that's a lot of
squares so here b6 black now prepares
the bus to open the queen side and now
rook a to d1 richer continues developing
and black
seemingly without without an active move
we have c5 now striking in the center
this should be back to b1 now the d file
is uh opened for for the white rook we
have bishop to c6 uh now putting the
bishop on this diagonal is the king is
on h1 so king to g1 there's even time
for this even though we're down a queen
so rook 8 to e8 and now bishop back to
c2
probably a waiting move checking to see
what what good ol schwarz will do
we have queen back to d8 and now b4 uh
arishevsky plays the the strongest move
ever in chess we have c capture sunday
for c capture sunday for and now rook
g to f8 uh again what do you play here
bishop to f5 saying that okay now
everything is nicely protected my bishop
is a monster here you can never capture
it because then knight captures on f5 is
just uh you know completely winning uh
so queen to b8 now again putting more
pressure on the knight here rook to f1
just defending so how can black make
progress here uh rook to d8 uh we have
rooked f2 now trying to double up here
on the f file but now bishop to b5 not
allowing this we rook to e1 now the
bishop can move we can play maybe rook
to e3 maybe put the rook on g3 bishop to
d6 going after the b4 pawn and a3 so is
there a way for black to break through
here black is up a queen black has a
queen for a knight uh black
it's uh
it would be crazy if black just couldn't
do anything here so rook to c8 and of
course we grab open the the c file for
her rook and this is how we will
activate our pieces so king to h1
and now rook to c3 a very active move
and now richevsky just sidesteps with
the bishop so he doesn't lose it bishop
to d2 attacks the rook and rook captures
on a3 so black is starting to make
progress here we have rook the g1
what is what is white preparing here
like we said it's very unlikely that
white can break through anything here
unless both of the knights can reach the
f5 square so here we have rook to a2 now
putting pressure on this bishop here and
knight f to g2 now we start
remaneuvering this knight we want to
play knight to e3 move the bishop and
bring the knight over to f5 so bishop to
c4
and now comes bishop to b1 attacking the
rook here
and here black has a way of uh just you
know completely winning the position
with bishop to g3 and this was in the
position after this it's very hard for
for white to find a move because you're
attacking the rook and if we eliminate
one of the knights then we know that the
f5 square is forever um uh you know for
black to use
but rook to a1 was played and now
rushevsky gets that crucial one move
that he needed the entire game knight to
e3 and now both of the knights are
controlling the f5 square and it seems
like it's maybe not all that much
because there's
a sorry schwarz does push f5 so he wants
to free up the the rook on the file as
well now we have knight e captures on f5
with check knight captures we have
knight captures uh and now rook captures
on f5 so eliminating all of the knights
uh and allowing black to
activate the pieces a little bit rook
capture sun f5 and now rook to a3 here
going after this rook the h3 move uh and
then with the bishop covering the h2
square maybe some rook to h3 maybe a
rook to h2 maybe you you're going to be
able to capture on h5 who knows but it
seems like a good idea there were there
were of course better moves but uh
it's a it's a simultaneous exhibition
when rashevsky gets to your board you
have to play a move but here activating
the queen would probably have been a
little better going after the pawn right
away or or via the c8 square also
possible but okay rook to a3 was played
and now comes rook to f7 check we have
king to g8 if you go king to h8 then
it's just a mate uh g7 check king g8
we're gonna play bishop the h7 check
force the king into a discovery and
after the king captures we can even
bring a third rook into the game with a
discovered checkmate from the rook on f7
and we get this really crazy position
with three white rooks on the board
something you really don't see very
often
uh but okay uh king the g8 was played it
is the absolute best move so the
position is still uh
uh you know
a dead draw if you will uh but bishop to
f5 was played now yeah and here
roshewski gives schwarz a very nice
opportunity to win the game but it's not
an easy move to spot it kinda is but
it's not so this is the first pause the
video of the moment uh feel free to
pause the video and figure out how he
could have beaten rashevsky
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this very
sneaky move that was made possible by
the white bishop coming to f5 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the move is of course bishop to e2
that's the good stuff and there doesn't
seem to be any defense against bishop to
f3 and that's game over the bishop
covers the h2 square
uh there's really no move you can play
here even if you play rook to f1 to
sacrifice the rook for the uh for the
bishop once bishop to f3 is played black
doesn't have to allow this black can
play rook to a1 but this is i know it's
it's incredibly difficult to find rook
captures on a1 and only now bishop to f3
check king g1 bishop to h2 with check
king to f1 and now queen to g3 and you
are getting checkmated there is nothing
you can do about this uh there's no no
useful check nothing you can do to
avoid this so it was in the position
however after this bishop to f5 move
schwarz did not find this he played
bishop to f4
uh and now well now it's uh much much
different and now it's zerushevsky who
is winning so feel free to pause the
video once again and win the game for uh
reshevsky while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on pushing either of
the two past pawns and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's e7
or g7 both of the moves are winning
because uh if you if you push this pawn
this pawn still protects our rook we're
threatening rook to f8 and if you push
the other one then this one that defends
the rook and the rook to f8 will win
again so uh rushevski played the g7 and
now there is no good defense against
rook to f8 bishop to g5 was played to
kind of discoordinate the rooks uh the
rook will no longer be guarding the g7
pawn but now not even rook to f8 to
check right away arashevsky just
captures the bishop with h captures and
now rook to f8 with check with queen
captures
g captures an f8 bringing you a queen
into the game king captures and now uh
if you look at the position after all of
this madness the material is completely
equal there is it's it's even bishops
all of the same color even that uh so
of course starts pushing his past pawn
he plays h6 uh when the pawns are two
squares apart from each other they are
very very difficult for for the black
king to stop uh so here uh three one
square apart is also very very difficult
because uh when they're placed like this
they create a wall that the the black
king simply can't cross but okay uh here
uh we have g4 now trying to trick
ruschwski now uh if um
uh well if the
uh rook captures then you have rook to
h3 check and you can pick up the h pawn
uh and if you do nothing then again
we've blocked the bishop's
control of the h3 square and rook to h3
is the idea so here uh boldly capturing
with the bishop on g4 and now bishop to
d3 we want this diagonal controlling the
h7 square so rook to f1 check and now uh
you can't even capture the rook if you
capture the rook then just e7 czech king
captures an h7 the pawns are just
unstoppable the the bishop still covers
the h3 square
so king the g8 was played but now of
course e7 is winning we have bishop to
e4 check and now king to h2 we have rook
to a2 with check king to h3 and now
bishop to g6 so guarding the e8 square
but now bishop to e6 check king to h7
and now the beautiful finish by
rechevsky rook to f7 check
and he was in this position on move 65
that el schwarz resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
the rook is now blocking the bishop's
control of the e8 square we're
threatening just e8 queen and of course
if you capture the rook then bishop
captures rook to e2 guards the queening
square we just bring a queen into the
game rook captures the bishop captures
and after king captures of course now we
have a bishop our opponent does not and
it's a very easy win we pick up this
pawn
and that's it we we queen this pawn
there there's no uh
counter play
from black here
uh so yeah
uh that's the game uh from the
1920s simultaneous uh exhibition
reshevsky not only won this one although
this was a really really impressive one
he blundered his queen very early on and
it was such a such an incredible blunder
i mean it it happens uh of course you
can see that he's a very strong player
he he really milked this one uh
indefinitely and black had chances but
of course if you miss your chances
you're gonna lose but after blundering
his queen like this uh pushing f5
allowing knight to f3 check and winning
this game so there is absolutely no
compensation for the queen you you
control more space okay that is uh
compensation in itself but you know it's
not a lot black played well black opened
up the c file regained control but then
uh he should have uh given back some
material uh to to survive the attack but
all in all uh incredibly incredibly
impressive game by the well i'm not
gonna say eight nine or ten year old but
a very young year old uh samuel
reshefsky
and yeah you can check out an entire
article about him and about his very
nice victories on the uh by edward
winter i will put a link to it in the
description below also you can check out
and support uh
olympic and he always brings us these uh
incredible games and uh always uh you
know uh brings us joy with historical
accuracy so hope you guys enjoy that as
well it will all be in the description
below
uh so i hope you guys enjoyed it once
again here we can check out this famous
photo so and next time uh you uh
someone sends this to you and they tell
you okay this was on the you know 17th
of may 1920 you're going to tell them no
it wasn't it was on the 16th of may uh
that's the mistake everyone always makes
and you will be you will impress your
friends uh uh to to great extent
uh so uh that's the game and some uh
vast knowledge for you guys hope you
guys enjoyed that uh i would like to
thank iran urban nima
uh stavros
and mikha kennedy for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh
whatever is happening in the chess world
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and just you know uh
continuing with with uh
some very nice chess games
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day